[Music]
in crazy girlfriend news she cut
something off I know it submitted by n
mu de numeral Hana in new middle and
Mada Mada number Ohana that's nice a
scorned woman is being accused of murder
after pouring sulfuric acid on her
boyfriend oh sure why don't you even get
that from what is with the the crazy
ex-girlfriend like thing where they
spill something on their partner what
the [ __ ] is that about
like hot oil hot waters dude that's some
Asian [ __ ] though you know like my mom
used to say in Korea with the pretty
girls in the school they would try to
[ __ ] up their face to like acid duo yeah
they did that or they would slice them
up with the razor blade oh so pretty and
they [ __ ] slice their face yes Asian
[ __ ] dude
weird place yeah it's a place in England
oh yeah with the Korean girls oh oh
pretty you're so pretty with a few
slices on your cheek you can't do you
even get this thing you could buy soft
dirt acid on Amazon what do you would
you put in a spray bottle
[ __ ] yeah and it comes back like the
wind blows up that's crazy
she bought it to unclog a drain no you
dear I know [ __ ] yeah the [ __ ] is so
fair what kind of [ __ ] do you have in
your sink you [ __ ] [ __ ] bad what wait
a minute wait a minute before we start
jumping the gun now let's hear the full
story
let's hear under no circumstance are you
allowed to pour acid on your loved ones
unless he poured it on her first on any
human that makes people Mel yeah that's
worse than getting shot I'd rather get
sliced yeah she also said that she was
using it to de-stress some fabric Oh why
she's bridge bridge yep
right
right yeah so this story is about
Berlina Wallace she's 48 years old
fashion student and mark then Dogen 29
civil engineer Kouga so this attack
happened September 23rd of 2015
okay so first of all this is the
couple's berlina and mark she look like
oh she doesn't like erykah badu that's a
she has [ __ ] flat I was a dope
looking flannel looks pretty ass you
know
but photo clothes okay I was like
goddamn they need the fuzz Buster shoes
like the most horrific picture ever
Cougars [ __ ] shot yeah so this cut
off they had been dating for five years
and they lived together but they broke
up when Mark began dating another woman
in August of 2015 he was cheating they
went with the white women at that oh no
it's she [ __ ] lost her mind
because she's like I have to keep it
true when you go black you don't go back
exactly is that the new girlfriend's
name was violet Farquhar Harrison what's
her warning sounded like Middle Eastern
eyes it could be a freaking story okay
so duck I know I'm just like let me get
to the rest so the couple seemed to
rekindle their relationship promising to
make the relationship work the day
before the attack
oh so mark has been ballina a text
message that said quote I love you I
always have I'm truly sorry for what
I've done
we need to work on a relationship you
and me are meant to be I've always known
that I will treat you as you deserve to
be treated you are my princess nanba
Lina I wrote it means a lot hearing
these words you are the love of my life
God does not make a mistake in this I
love you with all my heart then they
made plan for dinner but then Mark ended
up skipping dinner how you gonna say
those words if you're gonna break up
yeah you skip the dinner and
he went to go see his new girlfriend
instead oh my god he returned home at 10
p.m. and then they were arguing oh they
still live together yeah they were
living together and then berlina told
mark that she was gonna go stay in a
hotel but she returned later that night
and around 3:00 a.m. when Mark was
sleeping in the bed she poured sulphuric
acid into a glass she went into the room
woke him up laughing she splashed it in
the face in his face and said if I can't
have you no one will Oh sleeping with
any of you type [ __ ] yeah rabbit cooker
status so then it covered his face his
upper body in a drip to his lower body
and they're saying that it looked as if
great paint was poured on him because
the acid was just burning his skinny she
pictures of him easy the only picture I
have is the one I showed you and then so
I want to see the melting I thought he
was gonna look like Freddy Krueger - I
want to see that
so then Mark ran out into the streets in
his boxers he was screaming for help
neighbors picked him up and put him
under a shower while they were talking
to the paramedics and then on the way to
the hospital he was telling paramedics
to check on the safety of his new
girlfriend because he was scared that
ralina was gonna go an attacker police
arrived to the apartment and then they
found berlina
in her own apartment sitting on the
couch and then that's when police are
asking like boy why do you have this
acid and then she pointed it over to
where acid wasn't a cup and then there
was like a paintbrush there and she was
saying that she was distressing the
fabric and that she bought it to unclog
a pipe and then she was saying that he
poured the acid into the glass and
encouraged her to drink it but then
obviously that seems to be a lie why
what do you say that maybe he was trying
to kill her her story trying to kill her
and play it off as it's water or
something so she's like I don't trust
you that's pretty believable yeah it's
pretty good story I 3 a.m. you think she
came late right and then he can you at
10 p.m. no he came or what said and then
she left
whoa hotel and then she came back at
3:00 a.m. yeah yeah so then 25% of
Mark's body was covered in Burns he was
paralyzed neck down he lost the bottom
half of his left leg his left eye and
most of the vision in his right eye he
eventually regained some speech he was
captain ICU for six months and then he
was moved to a burn unit for another
eight months he fell into a deep
depression this is how supervillains are
created yeah that is [ __ ] crazy real
good that only kills erykah badu looking
women let me get two faces yeah I was
just gonna say that he's too fast
there's more set bad part to this so
Saturday what's the sad point so then he
was going to require a lifetime of
constant and dedicated care so he told
his father that he wanted to return home
to Belgium to be closer to his family
and then once he got to Belgium he
applied for euthanasia which is legal in
Belgium which is just a suicide yeah he
was approved after three consultations
and so authorities they ended up
determining that this was a case of
unbearable physical and psychological
suffering and so his life was taken on
January 2nd of this year and so now
berlina is on trial for murder since he
chose to end his life because of her
attacks oh my god is that murder though
a type of degree of murder
I think the asset alone should be
attempted murder [ __ ] you well I don't
think it's quite murder well now she's
on trial for life that is some crazy-ass
[ __ ] I've never met one person who
bought some [ __ ] like a satyr I'm kind
of sad everyone that I've dated no one
ever even tried to do that with me did I
like not leave an impact in someone's
life like that just so you guys know
they were both HIV positive oh damn this
gets sadder and sadder does his
girlfriend know violent right did he
give her the AIDS I don't know anything
about violet oh no you better check out
violet because she might be ultra red
violet now
that's crazy though because because of
that attack they don't look like people
with AIDS let me show you again damn he
lost his eye he got he's partially blind
and the other one lost his legs legs but
they don't look like they got AIDS
with this innate person the place I know
what yeah they just when I think of
people sharing needles doing heroin
getting HIV sounds your life
well yeah go to Berlin did I kill myself
yeah I would just just [ __ ] do heroin
or Drive you're just into like none you
got to do that
jail he has no other options of jail
yeah she looks so evil in that picture
just good so you don't think she's
guilty for murder no because he still
made his own choice I mean like if if
that happens like 20 dudes some dudes
would probably still figure out a way to
live and then some dudes like you he
wasn't able to overcome that I think the
difference is and the reason why she
can't be pinned for the murder is
because he never had a thought of
suicide until that event that she okay
so he'll suicide in general uses like a
mental thing that you know you're I
guess when people think about it it's
like stuff that goes on in your head
yeah but that is a very specific event
that caused him to want to kill himself
because he can't function anymore he's
not the same I could see from that plant
someone that's severely sensitive to
bullying say the same thing but there's
stuff like that too
yeah where they're actually going to
child because of like severe bullying
that led to death like weird like a girl
remember that girl who told her
boyfriend to go kill himself well if
that's true that everyone that's got
successful from bullying or whatever
they should also give their money to the
person that put them through that
because if that was me I'm like you know
what naca write a book about it thank
you
does she deserve royalties because of
like my life now and she was the
catalyst that got me there the logic
works for the bad it should also work
for the good so if there are any melted
face ballers out there they need to give
all the money to the people that have
melted their face it was the catalyst
that woke you up so it's kind of like a
dog the success of the first
no man every single one of us right now
it would be [ __ ] we owe all of our money
to every person that we met but that's
why I am MFP waifu and SP harvey [ __ ]
to know the to face isn't that Harvey
day Harvey Dent yeah right yeah user MSB
oh yeah great name melted face Bala
[Music]